- Oh,
- Man.
- I'm so sorry.
- Watch where you're going!
Little shit.
- Who gave you ownership of this sidewalk?
No.
- Jameson?
- Hey.
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Good.
We should grab coffee and catch up.
- Uh, why not.
I mean, I'm over it,
but if you need the
coffee for the closure,
then, yes.
- I'll text you.
- Cool.
- So good seeing you.
- Mmm-hmm.
Bye.
(sighs)
Will Mike be joining us,
or has he moved on to
sleeping with someone else
who's just a friend?
Damnit, that's what I should've said.
- Hey Jameson.
- Hey.
- You gonna have those
reports done by end of day?
- Yeah, I'm just waiting
on the last one to come in.
- Great.
I'm gonna go get some coffee,
might have to bring the whole pot
to get through this meeting.
(forces laugh)
- Or, we could just take an espresso shot
every time somebody says, fiscal year.
(western standoff music)
- Oh, Todd.
- It's Jameson.
- I see for once you
don't look like a cross
between a goodwill mannequin
and an underpaid vice principal.
I'd be surprised,
but I saw you download a
style app at lunch yesterday.
Excuse me.
- (Sighs) Next time.
- Oh, hey Jameson.
- Hey Kevin.
- Got any big plans this weekend?
- No, not really.
Probably just gonna
catch up on some sleep.
- Yeah well, that makes
sense since you work a-latte.
- Oh. (laughs)
Um, um, yeah this week is really creamy.
Or, is that too sexual?
Whatever, screw it.
Hey Kevin!
Headed to work?
- Yup.
Alright, have a good shift.
- Thanks.
Oh, and I emptied the dishwasher, again.
- I'm sorry,
I'm just really tired from having to cover
your half of the electric bill, again.
Yeah, probably best she didn't hear that.
(western standoff music)
- Carl.
- Still Jameson.
- Looks like the style app is down today.
- Oh, you know,
I was gonna shop at Basic
Bitch boutique, like you,
but they didn't have anything my size.
- It's okay hunnie,
you wouldn't be able to afford it anyway.
(tape rewinds)
- Son of a b--
(indifferent music)